hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast 21 CFR part 11 data
integrity for online TOC instrumentation
presented by Tony Harrison a senior
marketing manager at Beckman Coulter I'm
Suzy Valdez of lab routes and I'll be
your moderator for today's events we're
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab routes and
sponsored by Beckman Coulter before we
begin I'd like to remind everyone that
this event is interactive we encourage
you to participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during this presentation just click
on that green Q&A button located at the
lower left of your presentation window
and type your questions into the box
that appear on the screen well answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of this presentation also please
notice that you are viewing this
presentation in a slide window to
enlarge that window just click on the
screen icon located at the lower right
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of the presentation window or use that
Q&A button to let us know you're having
a problem without further ado I'd like
to now introduce our presenter Tony
Harrison mr. Harrison held the convener
of the ISO working group revising ISO
one four six nine eight part 1 and part
2 for microbial control in clean rooms
and was the UK's subject matter expert
to the ISO working group who issued the
2015 revised versions of the ISO one
four six four four part 1 and part 2
documents for cleanroom classification
at the heart of their septic
manufacturing chapters of both the
European GMP and the u.s. AC GMP
documents he holds a bachelor's degree
in electrical and electronic engineering
and is employed by Beckman Coulter life
sciences as a senior marketing manager
experienced in water system toc
conductivity and ozone analysis and
cleanroom environmental monarch
as well as particle characterization mr.
Harrison has spent the last 15 years in
applied metrology for the pharmaceutical
and healthcare manufacturing industries
prior to that he worked for the
companies providing process control
automation solutions for manufacturing
industries mr. Harrison was a joint
editor of the is PE guide to ozone
sanitation for pharmaceutical water
systems and was also the chief editor of
PHS best practice guide for cleanroom
monitoring he's well-known international
speaker and has provided educational
seminars on toc liquid particle counting
ozone sanitation for water systems and
cleanroom monitoring in UK France Italy
India Malaysia China USA Scandinavia
Ireland from Gary Switzerland Indonesia
Belgium Greece Switzerland Turkey Egypt
Denmark Poland and Italy and most
recently South Africa and Colombia
welcome mr. Harrison please we would
love to hear a presentation thank you
very much for the introduction hello and
welcome to this short presentation on
the FDA Tate integrity for online water
injection analyzes my name is Tony
Harrison and I work for Beckman Coulter
the manufacturer of the ANATEL online
TOC and conductivity analyzers a recent
report highlighted that around 79% of
the FDA's 483 warning that has issued in
the 2016 period to the pharmaceutical
industry cited deficiencies in their
data integrity
despite guidance from the FDA TOC
monitoring remains an intensely manual
process with many opportunities for
human error to create gaps and errors in
the data in
21 CFR part 11 guidance the FDA have
given recommendations on what good data
integrity looks like and this
presentation explains their advice in
the context of current toc monitoring
practices and shows how the FDA guidance
can be applied to improve data integrity
so stays agender or lasts somewhere
between 25 and 30 minutes so not a long
session today I'll touch on the history
of the 21 CFR part 11 a guidance from
the FDA and also dispel a couple of
misconceptions that may surprise you
I'll talk about the increasing
importance of online TOC and
conductivity in particular in the light
of the changes to the European
pharmacopoeia chapter on water injection
I also take a look at the Alcoa guidance
from the FDA explain what that is and
also how Alcoa and water for injection
quality monitoring work together finally
I'll explain the Alcoa compliance
solution from Beckman Coulter so let's
take a look at what guidance the FDA
gives on this topic and dispel some
common misconceptions in 1997 in the
face of pressure by the pharmaceutical
industry to move away from paper-based
records and to electronic record-keeping
the FDA issued their original 21 CFR
part 11 guidance documents on best
practice for using electronic records
however the pharmaceutical industry was
dismayed that the advantages or parent
advantages of electronic record-keeping
appear to be outweighed by the hugely
burdensome requirements imposed by this
guidance and there was a lot of pushback
against the FDA on their advice the FDA
realized that the pharmaceutical
industry we're taking their guidance as
all encompassing and recognizing the
need for clarity
they issued fir
guidance in 2003 effectively limiting
the scope of the 21 CFR part 11 rule to
those systems that are either directly
storing records toward by the FDA
regulations or those that are submitted
to the FDA under the Federal Food Drug
and Cosmetic Act and the Public Health
Services Act
the FDA's 2003 document provided
detailed descriptions of those systems
where 21 CFR part 11 should be strictly
applied and dispelled some common
misconceptions that may surprise you the
first common misconception is around the
use of PDF file type for electronic
records many people I speak to get
concerned about the fact that a PDF
document could be edited deliberately to
hide some sort of quality issue but
that's not the concept that the FDA were
trying to put across in their 2003
guidance the FDA sought to make it clear
that the 21 CFR part 11 rule was not
written to try to prevent criminal
activity it was written to avoid
manufacturers accidentally losing or not
being able to read electronic records
retrospectively many interpret the rules
enforcing encrypted file formats or
formats that cannot be deliberately
edited this is not the intention
just as with paper records the intention
is that the record should be kept safe
and secure so they can be retrieved when
required in the future again just as
with paper records it's not the format
of the record that the FDA is concerned
about it is the way they are stored to
prevent accidental corruption of the
information contained in the record all
offs of the record itself for example
electronic records stored in some
proprietary format in an archive that
only works on a computer running Windows
XP are unlikely to be accessible in ten
years time when it will it will be
almost impossible to find a computer
that can still run Windows XP
to prevent such mistakes the FDA
actually recommends electronic file
formats that are designed to be readable
on many different electronic platforms
one such type that the FDA lists as a
recommended is PDF which can be read on
Windows Apple Android etc etc electronic
records stored in PDF format are far
more likely to be readable in ten years
time that being said the archive where
the PDF files are kept should have
controlled access to prevent accidental
or deliberate changes or deletion of the
PDF files the second common
misconception is that all computers and
devices used on a pharmaceutical
production facility need to comply fully
with the 21 CFR part 11 ruling in their
2003 guidance the FDA go to great
lengths to explain that the only
computer that needs to comply with the
21 CFR part 11 ruling is the one where
the electronic records are stored they
even go on to point out that if the
final records archived and used to
demonstrate batch quality to the FDA are
stored in paper format then the 21 CFR
part 11 rule does not apply to any
computer even to the computer used to
generate the paper records in the first
place ie if the final record is kept in
paper format and not electronic format
then the 21 CFR part 11 rule does not
apply so now let's take a look at why
online TOC analyzers have taken on an
increased importance in September of
2004 the FDA issued their process
analytical technology guidance
encouraging the pharmaceutical industry
to change their reliance on the final
product testing and to employee more
online process monitoring in an attempt
to get a better process understanding
and process control leading to improved
right first time quality results
online monitoring particularly for TOC
on conductivity have taken on even
greater significance since the European
pharmacopoeia adopted its revised
monograph on water for injection in
March of 2016 allowing for the first
time the generation of water for
injection from reverse osmosis the
working group responsible for advising
the European Directorate on their new
water injection monograph gave a warning
that reverse osmosis may not be as
robust as stills and they encouraged a
focus on online TOC and conductivity
monitoring as early warning indicates
the potential reverse osmosis integrity
breaches so now let's take a look at
what other guidance the FDA gives on the
topic of quality control records and
data integrity in their 2003 documents
on the implementation of the 21 CFR part
11 data integrity rule the FDA issue so
use the acronym Alcoa where they define
good data integrity practices creating
records that are attributable to the
technician carrying out the testing
illegible are created contemporaneously
and they are the original record and
they are accurate in this case
attributable means that the record
should include an electronic signature
to link them to the technician who did
the test they should also include a
label stating where the sample was taken
and of course the date and time it was
taken the records of course is required
to be legible if not implies handwritten
records are not acceptable
the FDA goes on to suggest that
electronic records should be stored in a
format that is open and can be read on
many computing formats so it will be
accessible and readable for years to
come as I mentioned a moment ago the FDA
recommends typical formats
as PDF they also include formats such as
XML and sgml now we come to the see in
Alcoa in this context the word
contemporaneously implies the electronic
records should be created at the time
that the sample is measured implying
that manual transcription of paper
records is not good practice and that
creating paper records and then manually
transcribing them into electronic format
at a later date is definitely not good
practice either naturally there is a
danger with every transcription of test
results from one form to another of
making errors even scanning multiple
paper records into electronic format
runs the risk of duplication or missed
scans so the FDA recommends that the
electronic record should be the original
record created when the test was
completed
obviously manually turns transcribe
records are the riskiest attracting the
biggest opportunity for human error
finally the last pay in Alcoa naturally
the electronic record should be accurate
this implies that the process for
capturing these electronic records
should be robust ieat manual
calculations and manual data entry where
opportunities for human error exist
should be avoided
so let's took it take a look at the FDA
21 CFR part 11 guidance in the context
water for injection monitoring
instrumentation the FDA mandate for
water quality attributes for purified
water water for injection in organic
contaminants total organic carbon and
the toxins and microbial colony forming
units as I mentioned earlier the FDA
encouraged online process monitoring for
quality control in their p80
initiative at the same time the
expectations for the amount of quality
information is increasing and in
many cases the responsibility for
collecting this data is passing to
production staff a recent report
indicates 79 percent of the FDA 483
warning letters issued in 2016
cite data integrity for data integrity
may lead the FDA to call for a product
recall 20 years after the original FDA
21 CFR part 11 guidance was issued
industry remains focused on ensuring the
integrity of the final record however
many processes leading up to the
creation of the electronic record itself
remain intensity manual and paper-based
leading to the opportunity for people to
make errors in the creation of the
electronic record or even to leave gaps
in the data there are many manual fop
steps to be followed in the typical
water monitoring process are used for
certified calibration standards and
system suitability tickets are manually
entered inviting human error and
mistyping pass/fail reports have to be
manually calculated and finally the
electronic record is can be created by
photocopying the manual calculations and
manually typing the records into the
system quality control data integrity of
course is a vital importance and the FDA
could trigger a product recall if
deficiencies are discovered in data
records following data errors the normal
response is to initiate retraining for
the water injection monitoring team
however the industry itself and the FDA
is gradually coming to the conclusion
that this does not solve the problem it
merely treats the symptoms for a short
while until human error starts to creep
in again and that the correct way
forward is to automate this monitoring
program to remove the human errors
can make the whole process more robust
now let's take a look at the current
water analyzer prices in the light the
FDA Alcoa guidance there are many manual
steps in the typical process and usually
the paper record does not contain an
electronic signature so it's not
attributable to the technician manual
handwritten pass/fail calculations may
not be legible an electronic records are
certainly not contemporaneously created
through this manual process there is a
great risk that the accuracy may be
impacted as values for certified
standards are manually typed in for both
for calibration and system suitability
inviting human error and miss typing and
pass/fail reports have to be manually
calculated and finally the electronic
record itself is created by manually
transcribing the results into the system
so what can be done to provide an Alcoa
compliance solution for online
monitoring of water through injection
systems fortunately an Alcoa compliance
solution exists the ANATEL p80 toc and
conductivity analyzer from Beckman
Coulter automates all the SOPs and I
meant eliminating manual data entry and
calculations and creates an electronic
record straight from the analyzer
signatures are attributable and
controlled by the science IT team using
Microsoft's Active Directory controls
the record is legible being one of the
recommended formats from the FDA ie PDF
the record is contemporary
contemporaneously created and it's the
original record and is transmitted via
ethernet to the site's own secure server
where the final records are kept the
SOPs for calibration and system
suitability are built in and automated
there's no manual data entry as the
analyzer
the certified values from standards
bottles using RFID technology this
collapses the workflow removes all the
manual steps thus reducing the
opportunity to a human error and making
the record accurate now listeners today
you should be receiving right now an
invitation to register to download The
Associated white paper with it for this
presentation so if you'd like to see
that please reply yes and you should get
the white paper so that concludes my
talk today do we have any questions I
can answer for you thank you so much mr.
Harrison for that informative
presentation we will now start that live
Q&A portion of the webinar if you have
any questions you'd like to ask please
do so now just click on the green Q&A
button at the lower left of your
presentation window and type that
question into the box that appears on
your screen click the send button and
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for so let's go ahead and get
started with our questions we have some
questions coming in already from our
audience members mr. Harrison PDF files
can be altered how do I know if the file
has been adulterated sure not that's a
concern a lot of people have and as I
mentioned it's it's just as we paper
records it's not so much the file format
it's how you look after the files it's
important so in the first instance of
course it should be kept in a secure
data archive with passwords lock out and
all that sort of good stuff that 21 CFR
calls for having said that if somebody
was to go in and edit a PDF file it's
very easy to see if the file has been
tampered with by going into the
properties of that file because in the
properties it tells you the date it was
created and the time it was created and
then if it's been edited it tells you
the date it was edit didn't
time it was edited so clearly if those
dates and times are different and
somebody has adulterated the PDF file
great thank you so much here's our next
question coming in how do I avoid errors
when entering the calibration solution
certified toc values into the ANATEL POC
anele anele sir
sure sure absolutely yeah it's an area
for common errors when people are
manually typing in the certified values
of the calibration solutions but in fact
with the ANATEL p 8700 that's not a
requirement the standards bottles
themselves have a small rfid tag on them
which contains all their certified value
the use by date etc etc and when you
load the bottles into the calibration
Bay on the P 8700 the P 8700
automatically reads the data from those
standards and loaded in so there's no
manual data entry at all with this
analyzer and no manual calculations
either as it calculates pass/fail
automatically for the user
great thank you you have some wonderful
questions coming in here's another
question from an audience member does it
does someone have to physically go to
the Anatol toc analyzer to export the
PDF file no actually you can you can set
it so it's automatically exports the
files on on a daily basis of a fixed
time so it collects the data I'm sorry
collect the electronic records in the
analyzer then every day it's a certain
fixed time sends them out across the the
Ethernet network to the secure server at
least on the site thank you we have one
more question can you download a record
in PDF directly from the instrument at
the point
the yes indeed so the the analyzer does
have a USB port on it so if you were to
do manual grab sample analysis or even a
calibration the PDF files can be created
instantly and exported by a USB so you
can collect it from the analyzer if you
choose to do so wonderful we don't have
any more questions coming in at this
time
actually here comes one more your coming
in as we go could you summarize if you
are using the printed PDF as our raw
data and wet signatures how does the FDA
look at that again okay so sorry can you
repeat that one I'm not quite sure you
put it again sure could you summarize if
we're using the printed PDF as our raw
data and wet signatures how the FDA
looks at that again all right
okay so if I understand correctly you've
taken the PDF file and you printed it
out into paper format so your your raw
data your final record is a paper
printout which you've manually signing
so effectively that's the same as any
paper record and if you if you read the
2003 guidance from the FDA it actually
says that if that is the final record
and that's the record you go to and the
FDA call upon you to produce the
evidence for batch quality and you never
go back to the electronic record at all
when in theory 21 CFR part 11 doesn't
comply that's all that's what the FDA
say in their guidance if it's a paper
record you use the computer or the
system that you use to generate that
paper record doesn't need to comply with
21 CFR part 11 as long as you never go
back and then rely on the electronic
records again great thank you
a very captivating audience because
several questions just came in this is
exciting is PDF good to make
recalculations and or trending mm-hmm
so trending yet that's not good of
course what most people what I've seen
too is they have a final record for the
test itself but trending is typically
done from what I've seen even in a
little either in a limo system a
laboratory information management system
or in the cases this type of
instrumentation is typically done in a
on the SCADA system the control system
for the for the factory or that is
possible with this analyzer to export an
excel file or excel readable file so you
could take data out in Excel and load it
into an excel spreadsheet and of course
you keep the electronic record the PDF
records separately as the the file to
demonstrate batch release only only
going back to it if you're called to
produce that data thank you and I think
you just answered this question but I'll
go ahead and answer it ask it anyway
does the ANATEL keep the original record
in the instrument memory or is it
removed from exporting upon export
yes so there's two ways you can do this
is that something the ANATEL p 8700 does
have username and password security on
it an in multiple level so you can apply
the normal 21 CFR part 11 security to
the analyzer itself should you wish to
keep the record in the database inside
the analyzer but what I've seen a lot of
people doing is that once they've
exported the file electronically from
the p80 700 to avoid any confusion over
where the last file is and which one it
is and is it in the analyzer or is it in
the secure archive they set an analyzer
to automatically delete the file so you
can program it so it automatically
exports the PDF files at a set time
every day and goes back in and wipes the
files from the analyzer so it just
removes that ambiguity as to where the
final record is
correct great here's an important
question does the an occult TOC tell me
when something is wrong or do I have to
check the PDF output okay so you can so
if you're concerned for instance that it
was making TOC or conductivity
measurements and that were out of or
posture your alert level or your alarm
level so you needed to know about them
the ANATEL can tell you this it can be
configured so that it automatically
sends a digital signal to your PLC or
SCADA systems tell you there's an alarm
effectively or an alert on T 8700 so you
don't have to wait for the PDF file to
come out to you it'll tell you it can
also be configured to do the same thing
on the analog outputs the 4 to 20
milliamp output ski warming warn you
with an alarm as well thank you we have
a comprehensive set of questions coming
in and we have time for a few more what
validation evidence is provided to the
customer yeah ok so as part of the
standard validation package and of
course you may wish to add to this you
know each site has its own rules and
regulations that it follows but as
standard the analyzer validation package
that we carry out by our service
organization validates that the data
exported over Ethernet in PDF format to
the customers server matches the data
that's actually on the analyzer so we do
an export and then we check that the
data matches to make sure that we
validated that this export is one works
and 2 is accurate to the original
analysis thank you for that and can the
PDF be installed to p 8700 analyzers
manufactured before 2010 yes it's that
there is a software upgrade Percy
I was speaking to somebody doing that
very thing this week with too old @p
8700 and it works successfully
yes sir there's a standard procedure and
the software and firmware is available
from our technical support group
wonderful and here's a similar question
on that same topic network systems can
go down does the p80 700 confirm that
the data has been written to the archive
location prior to deleting information
on the instrument yes for sure so that
what the people at least like what the
p80 700 does is it at the allotted time
when you configured it to export the
data it tries to make the export if for
some reason as you say the network is
down and it cannot successfully make
that data export then it keeps retrying
until the network comes back up tossing
with a modern Ethernet network system
those sorts of gaps are quite unusual
and typically temporary and the the date
of the PDF is sent using tcp/ip which is
a very resilient network protocol anyway
but yes it will hold on it holds the
data and it waits until it's been a
successful export and then it it turns
out actually we're using File Transfer
Protocol FTP so there's a handshake
involved with the remote server so until
it receives that handshake it will not
delete the file great we appreciate all
these wonderful incoming questions we
have one more question coming in there's
a system control prompt preventive
maintenance so yes it would do the the
things that it's a very simple and
robust analyzer really it uses an
ultraviolet light to do the oxidization
to calculate the toc so the UV lamp is
in fact the heart of the an hour
analyzer and if something happens to
that UV lamp you're in danger of not
being able to make toc NRC
so what this analyzer actually has is a
main and a standby UV lamp which or we
measure the UV light coming out of the
bulb if the main UV lamp fails it
automatically brings in the reserved UV
lamp and to answer the question there it
would then prompt a digital output to
the to the site PLC that there has been
a switch near this UV lamp and it should
trigger really a routine planned
maintenance call so you don't need an
emergency call out it because the UV the
other secondary UV lamp should last for
a good nine to twelve months anyway but
it triggers the fact that you could do
is a scheduling after your earliest
convenience of a serviced all out thank
you and thank you mr. Harrison for this
wonderful presentation you provided
today with no more questions coming in
do you have any closing remarks you'd
like to provide for the audience No
thank you very much everybody for
listening today and I appreciate the
interaction I'd also like to thank lab
roots for making today's educational
webcast possible and Beckman Coulter for
being a sponsor today before we go I
want to let everyone know that today's
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing through April 2018 you'll
receive an email from lab roots letting
you know when the webcast will be
available for replay please share that
announcement with your colleagues who
may have missed today's live event
that's all for now thank you for joining
us and we hope to see you again soon bye
bye thank you bye-bye